[Music]
something funny happened in the spring
of 2020 while the world was teetering on
the edge of collapse in the face of the
oncoming pandemic a new nation briefly
tried to constitute itself right here in
the united states you probably never
heard of it but the western states pact
is a symptom of what ails america and a
harbinger of things to come
the last time we ran into a group of
states calling themselves a pact it was
the warsaw pact there's a sort of poetry
to it it rhymes because the western
states pact was also a group of
hard-left autocracies seeking to impose
their will upon the united states
left coast dystopias led by california
oregon and washington state coalesced in
april 2020 to look something like a real
national government and briefly
attempted to relate to the federal
government on a peer-to-peer basis now i
don't want to take the warsaw pact
analogy too far
after all in communist warsaw you could
still get a crowd of hundreds of
thousands chanting we want god you won't
be seeing that in san francisco or
portland anytime soon
but in april 2020 the pact accepted two
new member states in colorado and nevada
and in may 2020 the pac sent congress a
letter demanding one trillion dollars
for themselves the letter even had nice
minimalist letterhead emblazoned upon it
it's a design touch that's easy to miss
but if you know california you can
easily imagine some mighty bureaucrat
gazing with satisfaction upon his works
then nearly as soon as it began the
western states pact abruptly disappeared
from public view as the insurrectionary
summer of 2020 donned progressive elites
who posed the most serious state-based
challenge to the federal union since
1861 were diverted into a more prosaic
project of plain violence and mayhem in
the streets the pact disappeared from
public view but it didn't disappear it's
still around you'll see it
self-constituted western states work
group in the news from time to time
these days cosplaying as the federal
food and drug administration and issuing
coveted vaccine approvals heated by
absolutely no one the western states
pact was the most brazen attempt to form
a state confederation in spring 2020 but
it wasn't the only one the midwestern
partnership the southeastern coalition
and the mid-atlantic's multi-state
council all flickered into formal
existence in those crowded weeks
informal state coalitions also coalesced
in new england the north plains and the
dc metro region what's important about
this weird phenomenon why bother to
remember a handful of states who briefly
challenged the constitutional order
upon the formation of the midwestern
coalition minnesota's governor tim waltz
a democrat
explicitly called it a loose articles of
confederation scenario you'd think that
would generate some notice but it didn't
and that's the point we don't remember
all this because of what happened we
must remember it because of what didn't
we must remember it because the federal
government faced with this existential
challenge did nothing
doing nothing is what the federal
government does these days now i don't
mean in the usual sense of harry
truman's do-nothing congress usually
when people complain that the government
does nothing they just mean it didn't do
what they want i mean it literally i
mean the federal government increasingly
can do nothing not in a partisan sense
not in an ideological sense step back a
bit from whatever allegiance bias or
prejudice you have for a moment and see
the spectacle of the federal government
of the united states incapable of
everything but nothing
it's a new thing in american history so
knew it just crept up on us in the past
few years it's so shocking that most of
us don't see it because we can't pattern
recognition is one of those gifts of
man's intellect but it requires a prior
pattern to work
we've never really seen the government
in washington dc capable of nothing
before and yet here we are
the list of things the federal
government suddenly cannot do is nearly
a list of things absolutely everyone
left and right democrat and republican
expects a government to be able to do
the federal government cannot win a war
the federal government cannot secure its
own seat of governance the federal
government cannot ensure domestic
tranquility the federal government
cannot guarantee law the federal
government cannot establish justice the
federal government cannot provide for
the common prosperity the federal
government cannot secure its own
elections the federal government cannot
provide for the common defense the
federal government cannot secure the
blessings of liberty the federal
government cannot secure its own borders
the federal government cannot prioritize
its own citizenry the federal government
cannot handle a public health crisis
with any competence the federal
government cannot reflect and advance
the values of its own people the federal
government cannot assert its own
constitutional authority versus an
upstart larping letterhead bearing
western states pact
what can the federal government do
well try not paying your taxes or
protesting an out of control school
board or sending a joke tweet and you'll
find out they will try they will put
every effort into trying to crush you
like a bug
it's a late soviet state of affairs we
like to think that the ussr fell because
it's people's yearn for freedom but the
soviet empire actually collapsed because
in the end its government could do
nothing come the early 1990s the average
soviet citizen lived in a country
defeated in afghanistan shot through
with endemic violence stricken with
radically empty grossly grocery shops
afflicted by an increasingly worthless
currency and ruled by an aging group of
idiots whose governance veered between
insane radicalism and lethal
incompetence it was a country like
well like the one you and i live in
today
do you remember the name of our country
though
it's the united states of america and
that's the key to how we find a pathway
out of this predicament if the swamp
ticks grown fat and happy off the
federal government won't do their jobs
the states must stand up and do it
themselves in essence who am i i'm the
guy who does his job you must be the
other guy
treat the federal government like the
angry old relatives sending all caps
emails you want to impose unlawful
mandates by email you want to decide our
school policies where you have no
authority you want to control our travel
and bully our businesses and pretend the
10th amendment doesn't exist
i won't say the first part of the
sentence i'm thinking because this is a
family program but it ends
sue me it doesn't have to be that way
but that's the way it is
this incompetent decrepit federal
behemoth wants to impose total control
over how you live indoctrinate your
children snoop on your transactions
monitor your opinions for wrong think
and descend with their full might to
ruin you as they see fit
and they can't even keep track of border
runners or refugees or tell our friends
from our foes
author steve hayward had a line about
jimmy carter he wrote that he had run
for office on the promise of delivering
a government as good as the people only
to discover that the people were no good
that seems a lot like what we're hearing
from the white house today
but you know the truth you know who the
good guys are and the bad guys are in
this situation
so the question for you fellow citizen
of what was and is the greatest nation
in the history of the world is whether
you will accept this reality and
surrender to these incompetent radicals
or be wide awake to the fight ahead
i'm ben dominic and this is the american
crisis hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else